welcome to Jewsbury
a Yorkshire town that was one of many to
abandon labor at the last election
tonight the candidates hoping to become
their party's next leader will set out
their case I'm Sophie Ridge
this is sky news and this is the labor
debate
[Music]
in the Victorian splendor of Jews Brees
Town Hall tonight we're joined by voters
from across the country who support
labor needs to end ten years in
opposition facing them the three people
who think they have what it takes to
turn Labour's fortunes around
circus Dharma listen Andy and Rebecca
long Bailey
welcome to wall now our audience will be
leading the questioning tonight but
before we hear from them each candidate
has 90 seconds to make their case now
the order was drawn by lots first up
it's Rebecca long bailey thanks so
between the election defeat in December
was devastating across the so-called red
wall we lost seats to the Tories like
here in Dewsbury and next door in
Wakefield that after a century of almost
always voted labour and it was
devastating because we know what another
Tory government will do to these
communities we're here one in three
children live in poverty we need to
listen to voters they were angry and we
need to rebuild the trust that we lost
but no one voted against a better life I
know where we went wrong and I know what
it will take to rebuild trust in these
communities and as a working-class woman
who's always had to work twice as hard
to prove that I'm just as good I will
fight to win these communities back
again I came into politics demanding
nothing less than the best quality of
life for my community and people in this
country and in the next general election
is Labour leader I will make sure that
our peoples aspirations are truly
realized thank you very much Rebecca
long Baily their next stop to make their
pitch it's loosen and II thank you this
was no ordinary election the entire base
collapsed beneath our feet when nurses
annex miners are turning from us to the
Tories in their hundreds of thousands we
need an honest reckoning with what has
just happened there is a small window
when they're looking to us but if we get
this wrong again though
be no party to vote for in ten years
time it isn't good enough to say we
broadly got it right on brexit on
leadership on policy without any
understanding of how we had our worst
election defeat since 1935 that we can
just change the face at the top and hope
to fix this it's been 40 years in the
making in towns like Jewsbury
good jobs have been lost and with them
young people and spending power the
scars are visible on our high streets
boarded up pubs and canceled bus
networks people are growing old hundreds
of miles from grandchildren and children
who moved to the major cities where high
housing costs debts inequality and air
pollution are now the norm you have told
us and we have not responded but I want
you to know that I have heard you I am
determined to fix this and to bring
labor home to you but progress is not
inevitable if you want a different
country you have to go out and fight for
it if you want a better leadership you
have to go out and vote for it so I'm
asking you to put your trust in me
because this may be our last chance we
can be back in power in four years time
but this is the moment when we decide
whether we have the courage to try okay
thank you very much Lisa
Nandy and finally making their pitch to
the audience koh-sama
hello thank you for coming out it
brought your questions we've had many
hustings across the country of many many
questions and quite right too but
there's one burning question that we
have to answer which is how do we get
the Labour Party from where we are now
back to a position where we could win a
general election because that result in
December was devastating devastating for
brilliant MPs that we lost for
candidates who didn't make it but
devastating above all else for the
millions of people after 10 years of
Tory rule who desperately needed change
and now who won't get it and we've lost
four elections in a row it wasn't just
that election in December four in a row
now I came into politics to change lives
the Labour Party's it is there to change
lives for the better but you don't
change lives the better in opposition
so our party has a massive decision to
take in this leadership election do we
mope about
head in hands taking lumps out of each
other
divided no we'd be doing a lot of that
we're good at that but we'll lose the
next election if we do that or do we
pull together unite rebuild recognize
that the next stage at the journey is
for us
labour governments don't come out of
nothing they come out of our movement
and our party pulling together and say
the next bit of the journey is for us
and how proud would we be if our party
took that decision now that we're going
to get from where we are to where we
need to be and that's why I'm standing
to be leader of our party okay
thank you all very much for your opening
statements there well we've heard from
the politicians it feels like it's time
to talk to the people who really matter
the voters that these guys need to
persuade so let's get on our first
question from the audience let's get
cracking with that one and the first
question is from Phil Brickell from
Manchester I think you can see up there
at the top what's your question for the
candidates how are you going to hold the
government to account so they address
the issue of coronavirus first question
they're from Philbrick or a topical how
are you going to hold the government to
account so they can address the issue of
coronavirus and I'm going to go to
Kirsten before this question first
please Phil thank you for that can I
just start by saying as I'm speak for
everybody here that my heart goes out to
all of those that have got caught up
with this wherever they are in the world
because it's deeply concerning and it
doesn't look as if it's reseeding it
looks as if it's expanding and so this
is a really serious issue in terms of
holding the government to account
I do have criticism of the government I
think they have been too slow and I
think they've been confusing advice
particularly over where to travel or not
but I would resist the temptation
actually to go for them on that because
I think at the moment with this virus
what the public want to see is is
parties pulling together so I would
actually say I would I would point out
what I think they've done wrong but I
would actually offer on behalf of the
Labour Party that we would work with the
government and anybody else to reduce
the impact of this because I think for
the public what they do not want to see
is people making
two political points on an issue like
this so critical of course but actually
I would offer the government to work
with them if it was possible to reduce
the impact of this in our country across
the world frankly okay at least and I
saw you nodding along to some about what
what's your view on this I mean I really
support what care just said about not
trying to score party political points
about this because I have a lot of
constituents who are very very worried
about the extent to which this may
affect them in their families so I think
we've got to hold the government to
account and be tough and robust where
they're not doing enough we're doing an
earthen sorry where do you think they
aren't doing enough so I mean we were
doing this today in the chamber so my
colleague Jonathan Ashworth has been
doing a very good job at pushing the
government to do more it's not good
enough that we've got a prime minister
who has basically gone missing half of
the country is underwater because of the
floods the corona virus is spreading we
should have a prime minister who is out
there and on the front for making the
case to our communities our NHS is
really at breaking point we've had a
decade of cuts and hollowing out of our
most precious public service and that
means that when crises hit it's very
very difficult to make sure that we can
step up and sort that out without the
impact being felt elsewhere so we've got
to fund our NHS properly we've got to
pay the people who work in our NHS and
treat them properly and we've also got
to take seriously public health public
health has been one of the areas that
has seen the worst cuts in recent years
and if we don't take that seriously we
will find that we don't have an
empowered protected population who know
what to do and know how to keep
themselves safe okay Rebecca lund Bailey
how are you going to hold the government
to account on coronavirus look it is
important not to make this a party
political issue but we have to accept
the reality of the situation that we're
in our NHS is facing one of the worst
winter crises it's ever seen our NHS
staff are rushed off their feet working
all the hours God sends because they're
good people who became part of the NHS
because they wanted to help people and
sometimes we exploit their good nature
certainly the government does but after
20 billion pounds worth of efficiency
savings and cuts to public health as
we've heard I do have concerns about our
NHS being
capable to deal with a big pandemic such
as a corona virus so we need to
highlight the deficiencies of the
government's approach to the NHS we need
to drive forward increases in NHS
investment to deal with pandemics such
as this as well as wider investment in
public health overall okay
thank you I'm interested to get a bit of
a sense from you guys about how you're
feeling about coronavirus put your hand
up if you're worried about coronavirus
so it feels like a majority of people
then saying they're not actually that
worried about coronavirus so perhaps
reflecting I guess and the fact you know
that they haven't had any deaths so far
in the United Kingdom if you've got your
hand up keep your hand up again if you
if you're worried what did you guys make
of some of the government of the
responses here then it was good answer I
mean it's easy for not to get to part of
political on this whole the government
account because obviously the first
concern is the amount of lives lost but
it's gonna have a impact on the economy
it could have a devastating effect
impacted economy of recent reports you
know it could be you know beginning
Pattersons 2008 recession so so I think
it's rather we you know on the corona
thing we don't get two parts political
but you know do you think that and Boris
Johnson should have convened Cobra over
this definitely and I think it's it's
wider than just what happens within the
UK we're already starting to see the
impact through supply chains and the
effect that that's having on businesses
here in the UK so it's a very serious
economic issue as well as a health issue
and he should really have taken the lead
on this I mean I think this highlights
the folly of the government's approach
in recent years which has been to smash
up our relationships with our closest
friends and allies across the European
Union because you cannot go it alone in
a globally interdependent world and this
is a stark reminder of why that has been
such a tragedy for us and why we've got
to hold the government to account not
just on the coronavirus but on the need
for those international relationships
that keep us safe and you were talking
earlier a bit about some of the
conflicting advice as well weren't you I
mean we've seen people in Tenerife some
people wearing masks I'm not wearing
masks it feels like perhaps as some
computers have been conflicting advice
but the Prime Minister should convene
Cobra and take a lead on this he's gone
hiding he's gone
missing just when he's needed and it's
just it's not just on this it's on the
floods it is quite extraordinary that
this Prime Minister was out there when
those flooding when there was a general
election and now he won't go anywhere
near the communities and we've all seen
it across I think most people expect our
Prime Minister take a lead when issues
like this go wrong and to be out there
to I think actually convenient cobras
more important the planning of what
happens next and he's not there and he
doesn't want to be held accountable and
I think it's shocking ok and let's take
another question now for Matt the
audience and shall we and William
gettin's I think you've got a question
for I candidates haven't you thank you
could you openly and honestly admit that
mr. Corbyn lost labour to general
election in December and that you must
move the party back to the centre if you
have any opportunity to stop Boris
Johnson from enjoying 10 years as Prime
Minister questionnaire from William
gettin's from brick house not far from
here in Dewsbury a very relevant
question in this constituency but also
of course others across the country as
well that question could you openly and
honestly admit that mr. Corbyn lost
labour the election and you must move
the party to the centre to stop Boris
Johnson enjoying 10 years as Prime
Minister listen Andy what's your
response well there's no question that
Jeremy came up on the doorstep and
questions of leadership came up on the
doorstep on nearly every door that we
knocked on in the general election and
that wasn't just true in my constituency
and Wigan one of those red wall seats it
was true everywhere that I campaigned
and but it wasn't just that I mean we'd
had four years of nastiness towards
ourselves and each other for a party
that claims to want to build a more
compassionate fairer society that was
really existential the issue of
anti-semitism came up on door after door
after door even in areas where there
wasn't a big Jewish population because
people really didn't like it and they
wanted to see us change it wasn't just
that either brexit came up over and over
again we'd managed to get ourselves into
a position on brexit where leaders
thought we were remain as
where remains thought we leave it right
across this country wherever you were
people felt profoundly disrespected by
who so who's to blame them for that
brexit but I mean you've got the shadow
Bret's that secretary is standing next
to you is he to blame well it was a
disaster it was an absolute disaster and
I think there is a collective failure of
leadership on brexit that we have to own
up to as a party but let's be honest -
this has been a really long time coming
for decades people in towns like mine
and towns like Jewsbury have been saying
that labor is no longer of or for our
communities I won't like to change
that's why I'm standing to the leader of
the Labour Party I don't want to move
labor to the center I think people see
the need for fundamental radical change
in this country but I would like to move
labour to the north
you said the brexit policy was a
disaster do Holtz K stand out as well
for William I went out with 44 teams
across 44 constituencies in the general
election and all the campaign teams were
talking about what's coming up on the
doors of course they were it was a very
lively conversation and across the
United Kingdom and some of you may have
knocked on doors there was uniformity
there were four things that were coming
up the number one was the leadership the
Labour Party and anybody who was in the
campaign can't say otherwise
whether that was fair or unfair it is
secondary that was the number one issue
I'm afraid brexit came out of course it
came up and I completely accept it came
up but it came up differently in
Dewsbury to the way it came up in
Scotland and that was one of the
difficulties will come forth I mean I
won't duck that in the slightest the
third thing that came up and this is the
teams that I was with reporting to me
and they were all open about it was the
manifest they was overloaded they had
good stuff in but there was too much he
got to a tipping point where people
didn't believe it and therefore it
didn't matter what was in it because it
wasn't being believed and I'm very sad
to say the fourth thing that was coming
up was anti-semitism and it came up as a
values issue and it came up as a
competence
issue so far as BRICS it is concerned
what we were trying to do was to protect
ourselves from what Johnson was going to
do I didn't vote for Boris Johnson's
deal because I thought that it was a
very bad deal and it would end up in a
really bad place now today the white
papers been published and it's obvious
where Johnson's going to go next it's
it's got no deal or nearly no deal
written all over it and it's communities
in Dewsbury and elsewhere they're going
to pay the price and that's that's
that's why I didn't vote for Johnson's
deal because as soon as I saw what he'd
put on the table I thought it would
anyway has been set out today the
questions about Labour's brexit policy
do you take responsibility for the
policy actually or brexit secretary that
Lisa Nandi has just described as a
disaster I take responsibility for
everything in our manifesto it was
actually a Shadow Cabinet decision it
was actually decision our whole party a
party conference but I'm not going to
shirk from that but I do there's a
there's a since we're looking at what
happens next
leave remain is over so that divide is
not there we've left the EU so whether
you were full remain or leave is
irrelevant but there's a big test coming
up for all of us okay because we had a
problem cuz the question is now Johnson
is heading for no deal or nearly no deal
if we become leader the Labour Party
will we take him on or we will give in
to it and that's the question we need to
answer okay Kirsten we just said that
the Shadow Cabinet was responsible for
Labour's brexit policy as sown in the
Cherry Cabinet do you see yourselves as
equally responsible look I think we need
to recognize that there were many
reasons as to why we lost this general
election and brexit was one of the key
ones I come from a leave constituency
and I could feel the anger on the
doorstep from my constituents they saw
rose in Parliament playing parliamentary
games they didn't understand why and
they thought we were trying to attempt
to overturn the result of the referendum
and if you were a strong remain
supporter well you didn't think we were
going far enough in having that close
relationship with the European Union
well the sad fact is is that with that
lack of trust in brexit it took so many
other things down with it and yes the
leadership did come up on the doorstep
because we'd had four years of Jeremy
being vilified and attacked by the press
we knew that we weren't trusted on
issues such as anti-semitism and our
handling of that within the party and on
our manifesto the sad thing is is that
despite it being the most transformative
manifesto we've had in a generation with
the right answers to the right questions
that society was facing we didn't
explain ourselves and we didn't have a
message that spoke to communities and
spoke about their aspiration although I
had the worst election result since 1935
and you say that the manifesto was great
I tell you what nobody voted against
having a better quality of life and we
should have explained how the policies
in that manifesto would have delivered
okay but on the question about should we
move to the center the Tories are laying
a trap for us they try to pay page
themselves as the anti-establishment
party in this general election we were
the party that didn't listen to our
voters or our communities and we can't
fall into that trap and the only way we
avoid that trap is by having a bold
transformative vision of what the future
will look like and when we talk about
centre-right whatever you like I'll go
let you into a little secret those
policies investing in education
investing in infrastructure
reindustrialize in huge parts of the
north they weren't left-wing or radical
okay
they were sensible economic policies
that have been adopted by other
countries in the European Union and if
it's good enough for them it's good
enough for us okay
I'm keen to get a sense from you about
where you feel labor it should be we
just have a quick show of hands on
whether you think labor should move back
to the center ground put your hands up
if you think labor should move back to
the center ground at the next election I
know you had your hands up a little bit
earlier so yes so I'm from
stockton-on-tees and I'm not snowed
orient in an election and one of the
things in the general action one of
things that were said to me was you
offer me free broadband but I can't
afford to put food on the kids food on
the table for my kids and I think that
says it all really and in terms of
anti-semitism I think this is Norfolk
here and Becky how on earth did you sit
by the lead it's done by the leadership
when you know so many Jewish people if
they were made to feel that they
couldn't vote for the Labor Party
because they were sauce a disgrace okay
and well we are actually going to do
anti-semitism in a question later but
since you said that so passionately it
feels like quite a good time to actually
address that directly and I will put
your questions straight to Rebecca lon
Bailey and KS Tama
how could you stay in the shadow cabinet
case Donna I argued about this in the
shadow cabinet the shadow cabinet is
somewhere where you could take the issue
on and we had robust discussion about it
and I was pushing time and again I said
we need the International definition of
anti-semitism we need to change our
rules so we can throw people out if
they're clearly anti-semitic and we need
to open the books to equality and human
rights commission I didn't just do it in
the shadow cabinet by the way I did it
out in public on the media as well
making the case because I genuinely
thought that whether from a shadow
cabinet all the back benches or
elsewhere we had to take this on
personally I think it's a leadership
issue and if I were leader the party I
would say it's my responsibility to deal
with it I would insist that whatever the
state of the case
and the complaints they're on my desk
every Friday or whatever it is so that I
can see them because having run a big
organization I know that if you have a
line of sight from the person who's
who's leading it makes a massive
difference and I would personally take
responsibility for rebuilding our trust
with the Jewish community the test I
would apply as leader of our party is
whether everybody who has left the party
because of anti-semitism feels
comfortable returning to it so not a
rule test not a definition test but a
values test about our party because if
you're going to deal with this you need
it needs to be a leadership issue it's a
test of leadership and I would lead on
this differently okay let's bring in our
original question a question on
anti-semitism Talib chance Adam I know
you wanted to ask a question on
anti-semitism so if you just read out
your question and then we'll find out
what you make of the responses thank you
the overwhelming majority of Labour
Party members are not anti-semitic what
will you do to dispel the misconception
amongst voters that anti-semitism is
right in the party Talib and chanted in
there
let's go to Lisa Nandi on that most
Labor Party members are not anti-semitic
what will you do to dispel the
misconception among voters anti-semitism
is rife in the party well deal with it I
suppose is the obvious answers to that I
mean I felt very strongly about this
because I represent a town where my
working-class Labor Party members have
gone and thought racism and fought off
the far-right over and over again for
decades we saw Tommy Robinson off last
year in the European elections and if he
tries to come back to Wigan we'll see
him off again and they were knocking on
doors in this election being told that
they were racist when because we'd had a
collective failure of leadership at the
top of the party for years where we'd
allowed high-profile cases of
anti-semitism to go undealt with an
unaddressed and by doing so we've given
a green light to anti-semites everywhere
that they had a home in labour now look
I spoke up about this I spoke up about
it when I was in the Shadow Cabinet it's
the only time I broke collective
responsibility and I spoke up on every
occasion in the three years after that
and the reason that I did that is
because I am half Indian and I know what
racism feels like and I know that it
cannot be your battle alone to fight it
there is no such thing as being not
racist there is either being a racist or
there is being an anti-racist it
requires you to take an active stance
and to go out and challenge and fight
for better that is what I did there is a
serious question of judgment here and I
would just say this the cure is that I
believe that you are sincere about this
but if we do not acknowledge how badly
the Shadow Cabinet as a whole got this
wrong we will not earn the trust of the
Jewish community and those people that
you talk about who I want to see back in
the party will never live it again Lisa
you were in another cabinet when this
issue came up as well
[Applause]
and then I left and I didn't return and
I continued to speak out for three years
and you know the Shadow Cabinet was
offered site of the submission to the
equality and Human Rights Commission
which was investigating labor for
institutional racism and apparently not
a single person took up the offer of
seeing the party's position salute
nonsense to be honest about me out I
will actually happen I don't break
another cabinet it should be
confidential and I don't break the
confidences it was Tom Watson and I that
we're asking for that submission and
we're offered it so this is complete
nonsense that was what we were trying to
do I argued we should change the
definition to the International
definition I altered it four months in
the shadow cabinet and in the end we did
it I argued that we should have
automatic expulsion of clear cases and
in the end after those arguments we did
it we made something
not wanting to break shadow cabinet
responsibilities do you remember Rebecca
lund Bailey speaking out well in shadow
cabinet
I think different where we've got to I
think the last thing our members our
movement in our country warms is us all
trying to take lumps out of each other
about who did what the test for us is
how would we deal with this as leader of
the Labour Party and I would take a
leadership role of this in the way I
want to throw what happened well it came
it comes to anti-semitism that is fair
isn't it people want to know the true a
massive rise in the shadow cabinet we
were absolutely on it and we were making
massive arguments I was saying over
again once that of course in human
rights commission is looking at us don't
close the books give them access to all
about detrimental and bailey's because
Shadow Cabinet look Rebecca didn't speak
out in the same way as I did in my view
but I really really don't think and I
don't think it's fair and it's right for
us to just try to score points now off
each other in relation to this one see I
want to bring in a point in four weeks
time the test for us is how are we going
to deal with it as I mean to talk now to
battle and bail it's only fair to bring
in Rebecca
Baili at that point what is your
recollections of what happened in those
shadows I'm not pointing fingers or
making an O of the exact dates and times
that particular individual spoke at
shadow cabinet he knows that I spoke at
shadow cabinet a number of times about
this I was often the shadow cabinet
member that did the media to try and
explain what was happening and expressed
my concern many many times about how we
weren't tackling this in the way that I
thought we should
well the Tison seemed to be what he's
saying retrospective criticism of each
other has gone we are in a crisis and I
know that it's been sold destroying for
many of our members because we're not an
anti-semitic or a racist party but many
of our members went out in that general
election and they knocked on the doors
of Jewish voters who didn't trust us and
they were frightened of the Labor Party
and we have to accept that that has
happened and we've got to rebuild that
trust and that's why we need to have an
independent process for complaints not
just for anti-semitism for all forms of
discrimination within the party we've
got to adopt any recommendations at the
EHR see put forward in the coming months
and we need to also export it you have
an auto expulsion process but clear-cut
cases of anti-semitism and racism within
our party okay thank you very much and
I'm keen to come back to you but just
first your hand if you think the Shadow
Cabinet did enough on anti-semitism okay
it's pretty pretty damning and you do
just before about anti-semitism per say
this is about propaganda against a
leader who's fought anti-semitism in his
constituencies he's fought antes for
racism he's driven out of right-wing
people now that is about who who really
does make the benefit from this
accusation that Labour Party is
anti-semitic and I've been a socialist
and a member the Labour Party for 40 odd
years never once in a CLP or any
left-wing movement and meeting have I
heard an anti-semitic comments and
that's why it's propaganda
who who gets it the Tories benefit
propaganda listen Andy do you agree with
that I understand really frustrated
because most of our members fight racism
and they joined the Labour Party like me
because they hate racism as much as they
hate poverty and they go out and fight
it day in day out on the front line
especially where it's hard but that is
why the failure to deal with those
high-profile cases of anti-semitism over
and over again over four years we had
Jewish Labour MPs female MPs subject not
just to racism but misogyny as well
begging the party to take it seriously
and being told that they were it wasn't
an issue was so so wrong
and you said they were right-wing I
don't care if they're right-wing or not
right when racism addressed
Thank You Artie the crunch of a shaky
frat boy thank you your question I'm
kidding
we need to listen to other people in the
audience now thank you for your
contribution and I'm keen to go back to
our original question er Talib
shamsuddin what do you make of the
responsibility payers have been taking
chunks out of each other yeah
what really disappoints me is that as
leaders what you should be doing is
celebrating as well as challenging
anti-semitism wherever it happens you've
not celebrated enough and defended the
99.9% of the labor membership which are
neither racist nor anti-semitic and
that's the failure in all your parts and
go on I think your voting for none of
you okay because of that prefix I I'm
keen to move on to other issues as well
I accept the most of our members are
anti-semitic last time you mention to me
out but but one is too many and then we
had some in our party we're trying to
deny we had a problem and that is part
of the problem
I actually think for the vast majority
of our members they're desperate for
leadership on this because they do think
it reflects on them and it reflects on
their collective reputation they want a
leader who's going to sort this out and
take us forward so we can celebrate what
we really are which is an anti-racist
party a party that Jewish community came
to and supported for many many years we
overcomplicated it if you're
anti-semitic you should be out of the
labour party and if we've done that
quickly effectively we wouldn't be in
the mess we're in thank you very much I
know that passions are really running
high on this subjects got lots of splits
and the audience but let's move on to
some of the other issues I know you want
to put two candidates as well we've got
a question now from Sophie Kelly from
your watch your question
that the LED that the Labour Party can
be trusted to manage the economy
questionnaire from safety Kelly how
could you assure the electorate's that
the Labour Party can be trusted to
manage the economy Rebecca lund Bailey
I'd like to go to you first
well the whole point of the Labour Party
is to deliver a good quality of life to
every single person in the United
Kingdom and they have to have a workman
like plant to deliver that all the way
through from a detailed industrial
strategy to create businesses and
industries and prosperity within the
economy all the way through to a fair
taxation system that properly funds our
public services and to gain that
credibility we explain our policies and
that's not what we did very well in the
general election unfortunately the
comment about broadband that the
gentleman in the audience made before
there was an economic case for the
broadband policy would have improved
productivity it would have supported
business but because it was clocked in
at the end of a general election
campaign we didn't explain ourselves and
that damaged our credibility so what
would you drop down from the manifesto
I wouldn't drop anything from the
manifesto I think there were all the
right policies but what I would say is
that there were elements within the
manifesto that were deliverable within
five years
Green Industrial Revolution investing in
education for example and there were
other elements within the manifesto that
were part of a longer-term program so
the four-day weeks a key example of that
that was an aspiration we never have got
there until we improved productivity and
we'd rolled out trade unions and every
single workplace to push up at terms and
conditions for employees and that would
have been a long-term goal so it would
have been important to have the
manifesto that was deliverable within
five years but also Huggy a longer-term
programme aside that so you had the
worst election defeat since 1935 and you
wouldn't drop anything from the
manifesto no I think they were the right
answers to the right questions so the
Green Industrial Revolution is a key
policy it was in the electoral green
well I think they did it was a very
popular policy when you look at polling
as was bringing water and energy into
public ownership to bring bills down as
well as investing in the economy because
those policies would have created jobs
prosperity as well as tackling climate
change okay thank you very much
Leeson Andy and how can you assure the
electorate that the Labour Party can be
trusted to manage the economy that was
the question right well let me support
Becky on some of the policies in the
manifesto because I didn't get any sense
that they were unpopular I just think by
the time we got to the point that the
election had been called people had
stopped listening I don't think many
people in this country knew what was in
our manifesto because I think they'd
already decided that they weren't going
to vote for us but I you know in terms
of restoring trust on the economy I
think there's a few things that we need
to do the first is to rediscover the
language of priorities as one woman said
to me it's our money love and we haven't
got a lot of it so we've got to be clear
about what we would prioritize and what
we can realistically achieve what would
you lock them well I think we need to
start with issues like Social Care that
are breaking families across this
country and we've got to show that we've
got a real plan and if you have a real
plan you have to show that you're going
to pay for it so we all stored on a
manifesto that said that you put 5% on
the top rate of income tax that seems to
me to be broadly right and fair but most
people who earn huge amounts of money
put their income into wealth and assets
so we've got to be honest that we want
to raise wealth taxes to bring them in
line with income taxes so that we can
pay for a decent social care settlement
what kind of wealth tax are we talking
about we're talking about taxed in
people's homes no mansion tax land value
tax these are all things that we've
explored in the Labor Party over the
last few years but never quite committee
would you bring that in as leader then I
think we've I think we've got to be
honest with people people want a better
social care settlement we will deliver
it but in order to deliver it will be
honest with you about how we'll pay for
it okay and then that's how you earn
back people's trust and in many parts of
this country we are in power in Wales
and in many towns and cities across the
UK where we run the councils or we have
mares and in those places we're going to
have to go out and demonstrate over the
next four years that we can be trusted
in order to deliver the radical change
that people need and do so in a way that
is honest and that we can pay for I
believe we can do it and that's how
we're going to win back power in four
years time Kirsten
we're one of the wealthiest countries in
the world but the economy is just not
working for everybody I walked here from
the station an hour or so ago and you
may have done the same a walk past the
soup kitchen here in Dewsbury and I
stopped and talked to them and they run
that every week and it's freezing cold
on this between 60 and 120 people in
this town using that soup kitchen and
there were people with their children
queuing up on a cold light night like
tonight our economy isn't working the
statistic for poverty and children is
terrible 9 an average of 9 out of every
class of 30 children is living in
poverty our economy isn't working and
for mental health assessments it takes
about 18 months to have an assessment
even if you're 8 year old having an
autistic assessment so the economy is
clearly not working so the idea that
people don't want change I think he's
wrong but it's trust on the economy
isn't it because in that election I met
many people who said that this isn't
right it's got to change
but they didn't trust us to do it they
didn't trust the labour party to be the
party to bring about that change to be
that force for good and it's that trust
that we have to regain between now when
the next general election is but I think
it would be wrong in my view to take
away from the last general election that
people were happy with things as they
are they're not they don't like the fact
that our NHS is so grossly underfunded
they don't like the fact that Social
Care is in complete crisis lots of
people who need care and not getting it
and people want that to change they
desperately want that to change
they didn't trust our party on this so
Trust is key in this going forward ok
thank you very much for that well let's
move on to another question shall we
we've got a question from Jenny gale I
think of the audience and Jenny what's
your question why are you all so keen to
or seem to be so keen to distance
yourself from Tony Blair a new labour
when he was massively successful in
winning three elections and we've got
one aeneas
question-there from check out why are
all the current leadership contenders so
keen to distance themselves from Tony
Blair and new leader labor when he
succeeded and won three elections
listen hunting and well I haven't
distance myself from Tony Blair or
Jeremy Corbyn what I've tried to do is
have an honest assessment of what we got
right and wrong in government and what
we got right and wrong in the last few
years because I think it's only bad
being honest about what we got wrong
that we earn permission with the public
to talk about what we got right and
there were many things we got right in
government particularly the minimum wage
which was an absolute game changer in
towns like mine and put money back into
the pockets of working people that went
straight back out into the economy
health education sure start the
education Maintenance Allowance the
world's first climate change act these
were things that you can do in
government if you win power and it
really really matters but I came into
Parliament after ten years of working
with homeless teenagers for the charity
Centrepointe and then later with child
UF refugees trying taking the last
Labour government to court over its
treatment of refugee children and trying
to close down the family wing of y'alls
wood there were things we got wrong in
government and when Jeremy Corbyn was
elected in 2015 I felt a moment of
profound relief that suddenly we were
saying no more immigration slogans or
mugs
no more lack of compassion to some of
the poorest children and families in the
country we are going to be honest about
our values and we're going to wear them
on our sleeve again now I think we've
got to take the best of the last four
years and show that will stand up for
people in the benefit system show that
will stand up for people with
disabilities show will stand up for
Refugees but be honest about how we're
going to create that fairer more decent
Society and build the broad strong
unified team that will take us back into
government that's the lesson of three
times when we've won power is that broad
strong decent unified teams win
elections and give us reach out into the
country I know we can be that again but
to do that we've got to have an honest
assessment about where we've been
Baili Tony Blair the only living labor
leader to have won a majority was he a
good leader I think we should learn from
history and we should take the positives
from it in 45 we won that election by
promising to rebuild Britain after the
wall under Harold Wilson we promised the
white heat of technology through an
industrial revolution that would
transform industry in our homes and in
1997 we won under Tony Blair promising
education and aspiration but we
shouldn't look backwards because we're
in a time now that faces different
challenges and we need to have the
answer to those challenge what was he a
good leader in your view any Labour
leader who won a general election was a
good lead and we take the positive
elements from what they achieved and of
course we don't repeat the same mistakes
that they made but it's never it
shouldn't be a question within our party
about which leader you identify with
which camp you're in we're a broad
church and if we learn anything from the
last four years is that we've not been a
United Party and disunited parties don't
win general elections so we celebrate
our differences it's great that we've
got groups within the party pushing
different policy platforms but we have
those arguments in private and then we
unify behind the elected leader of the
party come what may okay the last Labour
government did really good things that
changed the lives of millions of people
particularly children in poverty
particularly SureStart I thought what we
did on shore start nought to 5 was
critically important because if you
change lives at that critical period you
deal with equality or inequality in a
really profound way and never forget the
good price to be preacher because you
have had more time than other people but
the Good Friday Agreement I disagreed
with Tony Blair and the last Labour
government over the Iraq war I'm afraid
I thought it was wrong I thought it was
done lawful war and I thought we should
have gone into it ok but that doesn't
mean there weren't other good things
done I would agree with Lisa that we
don't trash the last 4 or 5 years either
because what Jeremy Corbyn brought to
our party was much greater clarity that
we were against cuts to public services
and against austerity
that's very important I'm keen to get a
bit of clarity from the audience
put your hands up if you think Tony
Blair was of good labour leader
oh it's put your hands up if you think
he was not a good leader
so there are it's a bit divided but
perhaps more people on the side of Tony
Blair 128 years of the Labour Party now
and yet Labour's never had a woman
leader
Rebecca Leung Bailey does that matter of
course it matters because I don't want
Boris Johnson crowing on the other side
of the despatch-box if we don't get a
female leader this time because we've
got to change culture within society we
know what women face we know that 86% of
the cuts that have been brought through
austerity have fallen on the shoulders
of women and I think it's about time
that we have a strong northern woman
from Salford as our next Labour leader
case DOMA does it matter yes or no this
has come up as you can imagine a number
of times in these hustings and these
questions I don't think it was three of
us now before our party that any of us
are standing because we're a man or
because we're a woman I think everybody
is genuinely putting the case they think
is right for our party for our movement
and for our country and doing it in a
constructive spirit people have been
struck by how we're doing this and our
members will decide I'm very conscious
that this isn't the job of one person
anyway that it will have to be a team
effort and that's why I've been saying
to those that will support me I don't
want you supporting me as it were behind
me I want you alongside as part of my
team because this is going to have to be
a team effort going for so the question
does it matter but labour hasn't had a
woman leader well of course it matters
but you know we are all making the case
about where we go next and and you know
people also say well it's important to
have someone from the north or northeast
the northwest etc actually the leader of
the Opposition has to speak for the
whole of England the whole of Scotland
the whole of Wales and for Northern
Ireland and I think that's what really
really matters as we bring the country
together okay and Lisa Nandi does it
matter
yeah I was completely with Becky until
she said Salford
I mean I've been really inspired by the
number of young women who've come
forward since I started this campaign
especially young mixed race women if
said we feel like this is our campaign
and this is our party and what started
to happen over the last few weeks is
that a lot of older women that they've
often brought their mums to events who
said we feel like this can finally
happen and we can vote for a woman
knowing that that woman could become
prime minister and I would just say this
is that right across the world if you
look at the political leaders that are
going out and emotionally reconnecting
and making waves from Finland to New
Zealand's they are young women leaders
so I think it is time in the Labor Party
that we did that I think Boris Johnson
wouldn't have a clue what to do with a
bolshie woman leader time now to take
another question from our audience I
think we've got one from Steve Cardinal
at what's your question thank you
if I put you as my first choice on the
ballot who should I put on as my second
choice and why would they be the best
alternative to you as I leader who
should I put as my second choice Steve
Kerr more question there great question
and have to say Rebecca lamb Bailey who
would you put your second preference
what do you mean you people for unity
but just put one choice and that's rlb
all the way because this is the biggest
decision that any of our labor members
are going to have to take we've been
through the pain of defeat with green
comb all the stages of grief but we've
got to recognize that this could
potentially be a turning point we either
scale back our ambition and move away
from what we fundamentally believe in is
Labour Party members and that is
delivering the best quality of life to
our commune or going to put a second
preference then you're just going to put
one more preference for your vote no if
you want transformative visions big
ideas and the ability to win the next
general election it's Rebecca long
Bailey now who's your who's your second
preference going to be listen Andy well
I don't got one and the for a very
simple reason which is that I like both
of the people standing next to me and I
think they've both got real real
strengths to offer and I've said that I
would be proud to serve alongside them
whoever comes out of this contest is
going to come out strengthened by the
process not weakened by it
but I would just say this as well if we
don't get this right this time and if we
don't have an honest reckoning about how
serious this is and how long a time this
has been coming there will not be
another labor leadership contest there
will not be a party to vote for in ten
years time and that's why I'm asking you
to put your trust in me half-a-million
labour members so disappointing kiss
Dharma your second favorite sometimes in
these hustings when we've all stood
together I've been trying not to be
divisive and not to take lumps out of
the other candidates on any issue
because I don't think that's the way
forward and I'm glad that we haven't so
we're not I'm not going to get into who
would be my second disappointed would
say steam is that want to pay tribute to
the other two candidates because they
put forward really powerful cases for
the leadership of the Labour Party and
the leadership of the Labour Party
whoever actually wins this is before you
now as a collective and I think that's
very important and a lot to take people
have taken great hope from that okay you
disappointed for the answer I'm not
trying to sow disunity or just harmony
Bandhan within within the three but to
Lisa's point you know what what we face
here is is is a real challenge as a
party and I think there are there are
distinct differences and I think here
you're playing both sides and I wanted
to identify where you you sat in this
and I think I think you were trying to
be everybody to everything to everyone
and I really want to get a sense of
where you were aligned to and I think in
fairness Becky what I thought I would
hear from you and I didn't hear from you
is a nun Lisa is that there is you know
for leave voters our exit policy was
toxic and it was seen as a betrayal and
I am really concerned that how are we
going to win back seats like Dewsbury
and persuade people that voted leave
that we've listened to them if the first
thing we do is put a shadow brexit
secretary in the position of leading our
party and that and I hear you did a
great job in that but I just think it
sends the wrong message and I'm worried
about that so I'm just
people have an opinion on it I just want
to give you a chance to respond to the
fact that this gentleman is saying that
you're playing both sides it's not sure
where you stand
I'm trying to bring our party together I
think one of the mistakes we've had over
the last few years is we've been asking
ourselves which fiddle to party you from
not what are you saying I deliberately
want to bring our party together yes I
want people to come together in a United
Way because there's an old saying in
politics which is if you're a divided
party you don't win elections so I am
trying to bring different parts of the
party in my campaign I'm proud of the
fact that I've got people from different
parts of the party we've all come
together positively to be part of my
campaign I want to model what a powerful
Labour Party could be if we unite and I
think we will be so much stronger if we
just say well you got to be from this
party or the party or that part of the
parties that's a recipe on the paper
lose in the next election thank you very
much now we've had lots from the
audience so far but in some ways of
people who know the candidates better
than anyone is the three of you on stage
so after our final question I'm going to
give you the opportunity to put a
question to each other so one question
to one of your other candidates okay so
just a few moments have a little think
about what what it is you'd like to ask
at your rivals in the meantime we can
talk to Caroline Adam from Perth Church
who has a question for our candidates
yeah 100% blind and I can't see you what
what can you do personality and help me
look for you
so the questionnaire from Carolyn Adam
I'm a hundred percent blind I can't see
what one thing can the candidates tell
me about your personalities to help
Caroline understand you better
Rebecca long babe cuz I behavioral day
ever told you everything about my
personality but I'd like to think I was
down to earth
obviously I'm northern you can tell that
from my accent so I don't take any
messing about from anybody and I'm very
grounded I think my family I'm a little
boy who were called the king tell me how
it is and and that kind of drives
everything that I do me was he called
the King because he we serve Him we are
his servants in our house
and examples well every day when he gets
in from school he has a little routine
where he has a little luck and a
beverage lolly thing so he comes in he
goes mommy I'm in Jalali and then he
gets the orange lolly and then he'll
come in five minutes later and demand
the hot chocolate and then he gets a hot
chocolate and then they'll come out five
minutes later and want a snack and I'm
just there running around seeing to his
every whim okay I can definitely
understand the description how I think
parents of totalus everywhere bounce can
recognize a few of days things there
Lisa Mandy what thing can you tell us
about your personality to help at
Carolina Adam understand you a little
bit better I mean I suppose ever since I
was a child I've always gone to where
things are hardest and taken arguments
on it they're hardest point and tried to
help people who are in most need even
and especially where it's difficult and
it's unpopular if you were running to be
leader of the Labour Party you probably
wouldn't have done any of the things
I've done over the last 20 years I went
to fight for child refugees under the
last Labour government and ended up
pitted against the last Labour
government over and over again because I
couldn't bear the way that those
children were treated in what's supposed
to be a civilized country I came into
Parliament as a new MP fighting against
free schools and academies at a time
when Labour was supporting them because
I could see what they were doing to
children especially though what it's
like a personality I suppose just a bit
subversive really because in the last
few years I stood up for a brexit
compromise because I've campaigned for a
remain but I could see how disrespected
people felt in towns like mine I could
see what it was doing to the bond of
trust with the electorate and I could
see that we were going to end up here if
we didn't take that seriously
so I suppose what you've got to know
about me is that I will always go to
where the difficult thing is and I will
take that on and I'll fight for it and
labour needs that right now we need that
courage we need that ambition we need to
go out and fight tooth and claw to bring
labour home to the people we once
represented kissed on
Karin I'd really love you to come and
spend the day with me so you could see
me in what I do
day in day out I'm the sort of person
that when I see something that's wrong
or an injustice I can't walk by it
that's an easy easy thing to say so let
me give you an example we've had
terrible knife crime issues in my
constituency in HO penis and pancreas
which is Camden with particularly young
boys teenage boys being stabbed today
and when I was in the middle of some of
the really heated debates on bricks in
Parliament when things were really
really heavy I got a call from the
leader of Camden Council to say that
tragically we'd had another one of these
cases a Somali family and she said to me
I'm about to go and see the mum and I
said will you wait I'm getting on the
tube now I will come with you we did it
with no cameras no press anything like
that and I just went and stood with her
and held the mum who had just lost her
child because I thought it was the
absolutely right thing to do and I hope
that's just a measure of how I would do
politics we often say what we do in
Parliament the big things and the
slogans and all the rest of it sometimes
it's what you do in those moments as a
word personal decision okay but I think
and I hope gives you a sense of the sort
of person I am running out of time and
I'd love to get you give you the chance
to ask these questions Rebecca lawn
Bailey what's your question for someone
else we've got to be quickly it's a Kia
would you keep the top rate of tax that
we had set out in our manifesto with a
50p tax rate because you've been quite
ambiguous about your answer yes yes good
okay
listen Andy I feel a bit ashamed about
this question after hearing that Paxman
s compression okay I was going to say to
the other two candidates can we go for a
drink after this contest yes if so we're
gonna tour Camden and what are you
drinking
go on then it's a right answer for this
Kia wicked case and what you're doing
kink is Dharma oh I'll have a pint of
bitter okay drink gin what's your
question - and other kinds of it my
question is this if I'm if I succeed in
this will you work with me to unite our
party so that we can fight as a
collective force going forward to the
next general election together yes
absolutely
and more than that Alan I'll tell you
the truth like Becky says behind closed
doors and I know she will too and
together we'll get it right okay
thank you very much that's almost it
from Jews booth here before we go very
quick straw poll from our audience
he thought kiss Dharma wandered away
hands up Leeson Andy Rebecca lone Bailey
very unrepresentative straw poll of
course but there you go thank you very
much for being such a lively audience as
well I can see that you want to say
something so a little bit of pepper here
[Laughter]
[Music]
we have along the outcome of the last
general election suggests that level is
dangerously disconnected but from the
ordinary to extraordinary
in other words labor has lost his
position as true party of the people
okay my question is this how do we do
bit-level to restore trust in politics
stop the decline in labor support and
take the fight back to the newly elected
Boris Johnson thank you very much so I
think we haven't got time to get the
answers but I'm hope that you've found
some answers to your questions on the
show
[Laughter]
thank you to the candidate thank you so
much for being here thank you for the
audience as well and thank you so much
for watching the sky labor debate it's
been great to be here in Dewsbury thank
you
[Music]
hello there this is a Sky News special
programme on the Labour debate that's
just taken place in Jewsbury as their
three candidates to replace Jeremy
Corbyn tackle the party's landslide
election defeat brexit and anti-semitism
amongst other issues coming up we'll be
asking the audience which candidate they
thought performed best and we'll be
assessing what it means for the
front-runner certainly before this
debate Sakir star WA after Sky News poll
suggested death he's on course at the
moment for a convincing way are you very
welcome to this special programme on the
Sky News a Labour debate the three
candidates to succeed Jeremy Corbyn
having been answering questions from
that audience in Dewsbury a seat of
course that fell to the conservatives
like so many at the general election
sakir stahma Rebecca long Baily and Lisa
Nandi want the job of resurrecting
labour as an electoral force nearly a
decade after it lost power
unsurprisingly then all of them
criticised the Prime Minister they also
though had harsh words for each other on
the future direction of the party brexit
and anti-semitism which animated some
people in the audience personally